I'm Andrew Siciliano I I also do windows
and I'm in today for Rich Eisen on the
Rich Eisen show because rich is in
London and because we have a great game
on NFL Network the Eagles and the
Jaguars and he is calling play-by-play
at Wembley Stadium on the network at
9:30 Eastern Time sunday sunday sunday
how is London Rich Eisen how you doing
brother
I'm doing well I think hardly you know
what I've got to say you know it sounds
like everything's going well plays kupo
plays London Calling coming back for
brain never heard that before some koala
is a quality manoeuvre yeah
as I am calling from London and then the
IFP snafu happens but I am calling in
right now I've got Mariucci to my left
we're in the lobby of our hotel fresh
back from Wembley after we just met with
the Jaguars contingent moments ago so
that is where we are very excited for
this weekend brother how short rich is
the leash on Blake bortles you think
great question I don't think there is
one I think that the Jaguars realized
that this is the guy I think whatever
ails Jacksonville's offense I think
Carlos Hyde is the guy that they feel
can play the fournette role that they've
been missing and and and hopefully keep
the keep the the Eagles offense off the
field I think that's their their key to
victory here so I was talking to
occurred
on TNF first look we taped it Wednesday
full disclosure it aired yesterday
before Kurt flew out there to meet you
guys in London and I said who is going
to talk the most because you guys have
done a couple of rehearsal games Kurt
said rich that he was going to talk the
most is that right that's what he said
the most he said that on the TV it's not
right normally he doesn't really puff
his chest out like that sort of thing
you know look we got four guys in the
booth and that's a ton of guys we were
talking about it just today we're gonna
have another meeting about it tomorrow
about respecting each other's you know
spaces even though I've been told the
booth in Wembley's for two smallish
British guys calling their version of
football games so we'll see how it goes
man I'm fired up the town is you know I
do see Eagles and Jaguars fans around
town it's it's been a it's pretty cool
it really is I think it's amazing I was
saying before that I think I was telling
Kurt actually when we did the thing
ahead of the TNF game I think it's
fantastic I think it's a great idea and
and I mean whether it's one people one
person or nine people in the booth who
cares you guys have fantastic chemistry
I saw you put on the Instagram on the
flight over your your chart for this
game just like how Jack are you to do
this game forget about the other guys
look I've been I have been waiting you
know my entire I've been preparing my
entire life to something like this is
awesome games and it man just we just
met with Marone and both coordinators
bortles Callias campbell i just
instagrammed out a photograph of what
the chair looked like when Callay is
gonna you know and tomorrow the Eagles
the Eagles are on flight right now and
so you know I'm jet-lagged like crazy I
can't believe they're gonna land and
then play a football game that's what
they will be doing is there anything I
can for you is there any read yeah thank
you because every time I come in here I
feel like a kind of fish out of water by
the way thank you I'm flattered that
that I'm sitting here for it would you
like to do
the DirecTV now one off the top of your
head yes I can okay that goes right
along okay yes for those want to watch
the Rich Eisen show every single day you
can do it on DirecTV now you can get the
app right now you can get more than 65
channels as well but viewing on DirecTV
now all you got to do is go to DirecTV
now dot-com
right DirecTV yeah that works
no you get the app yeah and you can you
can stream our show a lot every day and
if you get the app you can stream it
data free on the 18th Wireless now
absolutely 65 channels for only $40 a
month there you go you nailed it DirecTV
now.com Rahman how you doing brother
yeah sneaky good games coming up rich we
had a winning week last week you want to
weigh in on the poll real quick you want
to weigh in on the player
okay so so 34 years ago Terminator was
released 1984 which movie franchise
needs to stop making sequels okay
Terminator die hard predator Pirates of
the Caribbean
Rambo Wow that's what I am there they're
filming one right now oh my god it's the
lone in it still owns in it okay I'm
gonna go with I'm gonna go with hard
let's stop let's stop I'm kind of with
you because the die hard they're doing
is like the back story of John McClane
as a kid or something who needs to like
just have him save another building die
hard lasted too long
when Jeremy Irons got associated with it
as Chris Brockman points out that that
is part of his filmography one of the
top films of his filmography which I
thought was ridiculous until that's how
he was introduced on Seth Meyers of show
well I didn't realize we have not
Khatami Plaza here yeah we do all right
don't - faux right
a collection the Hawks office tower
right there yeah and a little I have
enough stars the information you can use
is that the Jaguars have already been
here they arrived this morning they're
keeping the players up all day long and
then putting them to bed tonight and
then hope to have a full practice
tomorrow which they're going to do the
Eagles arrive today like soon boy and I
honestly I have no earthly idea how
they're going to get through the jet lag
at play game Sunday well good luck with
that we're looking forward to seeing a
rich we're up against the heart out as
you know well from sitting in this chair
we love you say hi to everyone
break a leg some tail on Sunday will ya
you bet you got it
Rich Eisen everybody the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience